at this point in the class you've gotten
a good idea of how jQuery works you've
used the three main types of selectors
and you've started navigating around the
Dom with traversal methods that's
awesome but now it's time to start
making changes to the Dom which is the
whole purpose of jQuery to that end
you'll be using the jQuery API
documentation in the next lesson and
rather than going through each method
one-by-one I'll be walking you through a
series of challenges where you'll be
tasked to take apart the jQuery
documentation to figure out how to make
changes to a sample page to get started
I want to walk you through the general
format of the jQuery API documentation